hey guys how's it going so today we are
going to make a cheeseburger I was
reminiscing on some old YouTube videos
and they came across one that I shall
not mention but if you can find it
that's what I'm talking about also one
of my favorite foods is actually
cheeseburgers and I don't really eat
them that often so I thought I'm going
to try to make one for the first time
ever so I went to the store thoughts of
meat great meat great prices
and that leads you to where we are today
right here in the kitchen a spatula I
get the meat where is the cheese si got
lettuce in case I wanted to do a lettuce
bun instead of a bun but I think I'm
just gonna do the bun and not try to be
healthy so I think this should be pretty
easy the only problem is I realized that
I don't think this is seasoned I don't
have any seasoning so I guess I'll just
start this up also don't mind this
camera is 100% in the shot and I don't
care just be careful because it's good
potentially be dangerous got our meat
our bun we got our cheese I guess I'll
heat up my pan I'll actually do this one
later so what I'm planning on doing is
toasting the bun and that's what this is
gonna be for how do I make a cheese
burger a main ingredients and cheese
burger our patty and cheese well I
coulda told you that
jeez a little oil in you to have any
seasonings what's this a versatile blend
of 14 herbs and spices why this is good
does that mix that around a little bit
it's best to use a cast iron grill but I
don't have one so I'm using this basic
skillet this is exciting
I'm making myself dinner heat the oil
the pan or griddle over high heat high
okay I preferred cheese is pepper jack
cheese so I got this tomato and basil
jack cheese which I think is gonna be a
nice a nice taste to the burger this
would be the most basic burger ever hey
dog so I have two patties but the only
problem is Jenna is kind of like a
vegetarian so she's not gonna eat it so
I think I'm just gonna make maybe a
double burger for myself all right I'm
opening this up that looks good
all right like I'll just put them on Oh
God
so what get a white dog I'll add a
little oldest flavor geez geez always Oh
God hello meat patties Wow just gonna
add a little bit of this for flavor I'm
gonna flip this patty back like burnt
did I burn my patio Oh God
I'm just gonna um put a little more of
that on there this is cooking a lot
faster than I thought like a lot faster
than I thought
I gotta cook my buns my buns me to toast
this is looking good
I get so much oil off oh that's bloody
wash you need us
oh no my buns are browning my buns are
burning buns are burning can you put a
piece of cheese on here I'm so flustered
my slab of cheese right there think I
might throw up all right bun you look
crisp this liquid creamy uh okay put
this on the on the burger put this on
here
holy moly ha it's hot pull God it's
really warm it is supposed to be
bleeding and I like to put a little bit
of ketchup on I just want to show you
guys that I can successfully cook
something I'll always you're doing
things that you can't see put a little
bit of ketchup on there or a lot dude
this actually looks good
you know easy it was to make this I
literally put it on the grill it's good
but it's very chewy
is it cuz you make the too quickly maybe
I guess I'll just put that one on the
ground save it for tomorrow I'm just not
sure why it's white haze Chewie what am
I doing wrong guys well thank you guys
so much for watching let me know in the
comments below what you guys would like
me to cook next hopefully it'll be
something nice and easy but this
actually looks pretty good
I think also maybe this the cut of meat
that I got might not have been a good a
good cut of meat
I'm so good later I'm gonna go have my
dear